[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire j'ai la joie de recevoir
aujourd'hui le plus jeune invité de
cette émission
raphaël charlene n'a que 16 ans il vient
de publier printemps rouge sur la
commune de paris aux éditions maya alors
pourquoi écrire sur une révolution qui
n'a duré que 72 jours
il y à 150 ans quand on est né au 21e
siècle et que l'on vit depuis six mois
sous un régime sans précédent celui de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est ce que
nous allons voir mais commençons comme
c'est la tradition dans cette émission
par une image alors normalement c'est
une image de notre époque mais voici
celle que vous avez choisi rafale elle
est juste derrière moi c'est une image
de la commune pourquoi celle-ci alors
cette photo je les choisis tout d'abord
parce qu'il ya une véritable énergie qui
se dégage qui gagent de l'image on voit
on sent véritablement la détermination
des membres de la commune présent on
voit également leur diversité et c'est
ça que j'ai trouvé intéressant puisque
tout à droite vous avez finalement un
jeune homme alors que dans la masse des
soldats vous avez des personnes un peu
plus âgé mais ce qui m'intéresse le plus
dans cette photo véritablement c'est la
nuance de couleur puisqu'elle varie du
clair tout à gauche au plus foncé tout à
droite alors je ne pense pas que se
dégrade et soit voulue de la part du
photographe qui est qui qui est capturé
cette image mais il est symboliquement
très fort puisque la commune se place
dans un contexte politique extrêmement
chaotique lempire vient de s'effondrer
et la république a du mal à naître alors
c'est une période de clair-obscur
politique de doute et il ya une formule
d'antonio gramsci qui était un militant
marxiste et socialiste italien que
j'aime beaucoup qui dit le vieux monde
se meurt le nouveau monde tarder à
apparaître et dans ce clair obscur
surgissent les monstres la commune comme
d'autres mouvements populaires au cours
des deux derniers siècles qui ont pris
des formes extrêmement diverses est un
exemple que ces moments de claix rock de
clair-obscur pardon peuvent également
favoriser l'émergence de belle
mobilisation sociale politique et
solidaire nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une période de clair obscur
personne ne sait quand et si la crise
sanitaire prendra fin et les suites
politiques et économiques de celle ci
demeure encore incertaine alors comme le
disait g ce qui les monstres peuvent
s'emparer cette période de doute mais
les citoyens et plus largement le puck
peuvent également décider de ce qu'il
adviendra celle ci voici donc 150 après
quelle surprise
ce que cette photo nous disent
aujourd'hui elle nous dit simplement de
ne pas laisser la construction du fameux
monde d'après à ceux qui ont fait le
monde d'avant voilà donc pourquoi même
avec un demi siècle d'âge
elle me semble illustrer parfaitement ce
qui peut être venir de notre époque elle
a aussi ce site particulier cette photo
c'est que le canon est dirigée sur celui
qui la regarde et est-ce que tu une
image très très moderne le au cinéma il
faudra attendre encore au moins 40 ans
pour qu'on voit pour la première fois
ces tacots boy d'ailleurs qui regarde la
caméra comme ça et qui tirent sur la
caméra dans un western très célèbre et
esca non la bouche de ce canon elle
aussi elle est assez impressionnante
tout à fait c'est en plus elle est très
laisse entrer véritablement au beau
milieu de l'image et ça montre quand je
parlais de la détermination des fédérés
à mon avis elle passe aussi par leur
envie véritablement de changer les
choses et parfois de manière radicale
comme ça a été le cas sous la commune
donc la bouche de la bouche de ce cas de
ce cannes ont dressé vers le photographe
elle me semble avant tout symboliser
véritablement cette détermination et
cette ce beau point de changement voilà
enfin charley vous êtes lycéen vous
publiez printemps rouge aux éditions
maya c'est votre troisième essai le
premier larmes à gauche est paru fin
2019 vous aviez quoi 14 ans 15 ans alors
14 ans au moment de la rédaction et 15
au moment de la publication
alors c'était sous titré analyse concise
et militante de la gauche de 2017 à 2019
le deuxième la fracture date de juin
2020 c'est sur la ville que vous habitez
boulogne billancourt
à la lumière des élections municipales
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
la politique vous intéresse la quatrième
de couverture de printemps rouge avertit
d'ailleurs le lecteur que vous êtes
militant communiste alors pourquoi la
commune il ne s'est rien passé de plus
exaltant depuis que vous
depuis pour que vous vous soyez
retourner cent cinquante ans en arrière
vous plonger dans cette eau douce dans
ce bain de jouvence
il y en a eu pour tant d'autres des
printemps rouge en russie en chine à
cuba au vietnam qu'est ce que la commune
est de particulier à vos yeux
alors c'est une c'est une très bonne
question
en fait ce qui m'a beaucoup plu j'avais
envie de prendre un petit peu de recul
vis-à-vis de l'actualité parce que mes
deux premiers essais sont véritablement
ancré dans la politique dans la
politique telle que nous la vivons
aujourd'hui
et pour le coup j'avais envie de prendre
de parler des révolutions du passé alors
pourquoi la commune tout simplement
parce que l'occasion de des 150 ans de
l'événement m'a finalement décidé à
écrire dessus en disant que c'était une
occasion et que finalement la commune
est riche en enseignements notamment en
enseignement politique du point de vue
du programme politique de la commune
puisque c'est notamment elle qui bien
avant la loi de 1905 a décrété la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
l'instauration d'un service minimum dans
les salaires minimums pardon dans les
services publics c'est également une
oeuvre de la commune la limitation de
des journées de travail de même donc
véritablement je crois que cet épisode a
été peut-être en avance sur son temps et
est encore aujourd'hui très intéressant
à analyser et à mon avis c'est son
actualité qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il
revient dans nos débats et qu'il y ait
un tel engouement autour de son
anniversaire
alors moi je me souviens j'étais plus
jeune que vous mais je me souviens du
cinquantenaire de la commune c'était en
on était trois ans après mai 68 donc
savez forcément influencé le regard
qu'ont porté sur la commune
elles auront dit voyez quelque chose de
très romantique c'étaient des jeunes
gens un peu fou un peu fou qui s'étaient
dressés comme ça contre l'armée
versaillaise et puis on avait beaucoup
de sa vie insisté sur sa répression
c'est la répression qui était qui et
quelle époque que j'ai l'impression
qu'on compte qu on commémorait
aujourd'hui on dirait que c'est très
différent 1
je crois que il ya plusieurs choses
aujourd'hui la commune elles m'ont la
répression de la commune montre avant
tout l'horreur bas tout simplement d'un
d'un gouvernement qui est d'un
gouvernement plutôt autoritaire qui est
en train de perdre qui est en train de
perdre pied et qui veut absolument
écrasé les mouvements républicains
véritablement et aurait pu les sauver
les socios qui s'empare de paris ii et
de la france en général mais
particulièrement de paris puisque la
commune de paris a été celle qui a duré
le plus longtemps donc la répression
elle a aussi un effectivement commémorer
la répression c'est un petit peu c'est
absolument pas le propos ici mais elle
est véritablement importante et elle
montre que elle montre véritablement une
envie de pouvoir de la part de la part
de ceux qui gouvernent et finalement que
la perte de ce pouvoir peut les conduire
à la répression extrêmement violente
puisque
la commune on parle de chiffres pendant
la semaine sanglante qui a au moment de
sa fin entre 6000 et 30 mille tués au
cours de la semaine sanglante et plus de
43 mille arrestations dont près de la
moitié aboutir finalement à des
acquittements
donc effectivement elle me semble être
symbolique cette répression et a surtout
très a surtout très importante parce que
elle elle me semble être politiquement
révélatrice voilà alors il faut il faut
comprendre aussi que en 1871 quand a
lieu la commune
en fait paris c'est sa quatrième
révolution en moins d'un siècle
c'est un record historique à personne
aucun pays n'a connu des choses
pareilles
la première évolution sans 1789 alors en
1871 plus personne n'est là qu'à vécu
1789 mais en revanche il ya ceux qui ont
connu 1830 il ya ceux qui ont connu 1848
et puis et et notamment dans l'autre
camp c'est à dire le camp des
conservateurs le camp des des dominants
le camp de dale faîtière on a des
souvenirs absolument atroces de la
révolution un pour eux la révolution
c'est là c'est la destruction ce sont
les exactions ce sont les violences
notamment contre l'église et je pense
que ça ça explique aussi la férocité
avec laquelle va être réprimé la la
commune de paris effectivement il ya
tout d'abord une véritable corrélation
entre toutes les révolutions du 19e
siècle
et là ils arrivés là révolution
française évidemment au point que iliad
il ya des exemples extrêmement célèbre
notamment le général galliffet donc qui
était un haut gradé de l'armée
versaillaise qui à la fin de la semaine
sanglante lorsqu il emmène une partie
des prisonniers communards finalement en
dehors de paris s'arrête et et ordonne
aux prisonniers qui ont les cheveux
blancs de sortir des rangs à ce moment
là il est à ce moment là il leur dit
vous vous avez connu la révolution de
1848 vous êtes encore plus coupable que
les autres et et finalement ils les
exécute donc effectivement il ya une
continuité dans les mouvements
révolutionnaires du 19e siècle et
j'inclus ici aussi la révolution de 1789
après effectivement je crois que c est
ce que la férocité des communards a
finalement vis-à-vis de certaines
instances comme par exemple
l'église on en a parlé à finalement
quelque part enclenché la répression
pour le coup je ne le crois pas puisque
les communards ont réellement
certes il ya eu il ya eu des des scènes
absolument des scènes absolument 200
condamnables il faut le dire mais mais
mais je crois véritablement que ce n'est
pas pour ça qu'on a eu une telle
répression
il ya des exemples notamment celui d'un
révolutionnaire auguste blanqui qui
était détenu par tiers en bretagne et
qui refusait absolument de libérer alors
la commune décide finalement de proposer
les change de tous les otages versailles
est d'importance contre la seule
personne de blanc qui est finalement
tiers a refusé cet échange le la
férocité des que la férocité des
communards sur certains points a
véritablement été plus une manière pour
tiers de justifier la répression plus
qu'autre chose et cet exemple à mon avis
des prisonniers et de blanc qui est
important alors je me suis mal compris
je parlais de la férocité de la
répression
pas de la férocité des communards même
si effectivement ils ont ils ont eux
aussi fusillé
on va on va en parler mais c'est la
férocité de la répression qui pour moi
s'explique par la peur des révolutions
précédente et et notamment quand le
délit est fait allusion à 48
il fait patent allusion à la révolution
qui qui nous débarrasse de
louis-philippe qu'aux journées de juin
48 c'est à dire à la révolution
parisienne réprimer déjà férocement
parler par la république tout jeune
parce qu'on a peur à chaque fois de la
révolution dans la révolution
on a peur de la révolution sont entre la
république et
quelle que soit la république qu'on
espère à ce moment là parce que la
république la révolution à ce moment là
c'est la destruction
c'est le sait ce que va être d'une
certaine manière la commune aussi parce
qu'elle va se finir dans les flammes
comme on va le voir et une partie de
paris va être détruite et on va le
reprocher aux communards et souvent aux
femmes d'ailleurs qu'on appellera les
pétroleuses mais pour avancer la commune
de paris est indissociable du siège de
paris le siège de paris va durer du 18
septembre au 28 janvier
paris refusait de se rendre à ce moment
là les les prussiens qui avait largement
battu l'armée impériale et est fait
prisonnier d'appeler au trône en cercle
paris ils sont extrêmement bien armée
ils sont très nombreux très puissant
paris n'a absolument aucune chance
et pourtant on a toute une population
qui va se dresser fièrement refusé de se
rendre et d'ailleurs quand la commune
est proclamée l'armistice a été signé
mais on voit bien que les prussiens sont
toujours là on voit bien que ce peuple
qui continue de vouloir en découdre
alors qu'il a souffert pendant des mois
de la famine qui a été extrêmement
affaibli que là aussi pendant la commune
il est face à 120 mille soldats de
l'armée versaillaise ils n'ont aucune
chance c'est cette volonté d'en découdre
moi qui me qui me fascine sur cette
époque là quand on voit à quel point
par la suite on a pu facilement rendre
les armes dans différentes occasions on
se dit qu'est ce qui faisait que ces
gens là vous voulez à ce point se battre
je crois que c'était en partie notamment
le un sentiment de ras-le-bol vis-à-vis
des trahisons qui qui ont succédé et qui
se sont succédé de la part du
gouvernement vis-à-vis des parisiens je
prend notamment l'exemple de léon
gambetta qui lorsqu'ils quittent paris
certifie au peuple parisien qui est
farouchement opposé à la reddition qu'il
ne rendra pas les armes aux prussiens
finalement quelques quelques mois plus
tard c'est ce qui est fait donc ce
sentiment d'avoir été abandonné par son
propre par son propre gouvernement qui à
mon avis a favorisé
à favoriser tout simplement le sentiment
de révolte est également tout simplement
un sentiment de ras-le-bol plus générale
vis-à-vis des conditions de vie dans
lequel vivaient les parisiens les plus
pauvres il ya le discours de victor hugo
sur la misère alors qu'il n'est pas qui
n'est pas de la même époque
mais du même siècle et où véritablement
on a on a l'image de ce parc de ces
quartiers de paris
véritablement laissé en proie à la
misère et la pauvreté et je crois qu'il
n'y avait pas d'autre solution pour
paris si jamais elle voulait se défendre
et relever la tête que ce que
l'insurrection de la commune bismarck
d'ailleurs pendant tout le temps où il a
siégé paris n'a jamais attaqué paris on
bombarde on affame mais on n'attaque pas
et il a raison pour laquelle on
n'attaque pas c'est une bismarck qui a
été ambassadeur à paris du royaume de
prusse est persuadé que les parisiens
vont finir par s'entretuer et il n'a pas
tort parce que la gauche radicale celle
qui va alimenter la commune ensuite à
plusieurs reprises tente d insurrection
contre le gouvernement de défense
nationale donc issu de cette toute jeune
république qui vient de s'autoproclamer
république mais qui n'est pas sûr d'en
avoir pour très très longtemps et
bismarck il est persuadé que les et les
parisiens vont s'entre pied et ils
s'entretuent tout à fait mais bismarck à
une stratégie bien précise puisque au
moment où finalement la commune est
proclamée tiers tiers fut paris pour
versailles véritablement bismarck
n'intervient pas avec sa propre armée
mais aide largement le gouvernement deux
tiers à réprimer à réprimer la
révolution parisienne puisqu'il fait
libérer des soldats deux des soldats
français
ces prisonniers pendant la guerre et il
les renvoie à paris et enfin à
versailles pour aider tiers dans son
combat contre contre contre la commune
donc certes il n'est pas intervenu
il savait que les divisions politiques
internes
rongé la france mais il a quand même su
tirer son épingle du jeu et surtout je
vois une stratégie politique bien
précise qu'il a finalement conduit à
remporter une victoire puisque les
conditions de
des traités de reddition et notamment la
cession de certains territoires à à la
prusse ont été ont été finalement ont
été finalement acceptée et ont eu lieu
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que la puck commune
et proclamé le 18 mars alors c'est
toujours celle à faire des canons je la
rappelle rapidement
il ya des canons dans paris qui était là
pour se défendre contre le siège ils
sont généralement sur les hauteurs et
pendant la nuit tiers envoie l'armée
récupérer ses canons parce qu'il se
méfie de la population parisienne
et puis ça se passe pas aussi bien que
ça devrait lille et paris via ce réveil
voit les soldats autour de leurs canons
notamment à montmartre et et là c'est le
début de l'insurrection et deux généraux
vont être exécutés immédiatement par la
foule
ce serait ça le déclenchement de la
commune
mais alors vous qui vous êtes penché sur
la question aujourd'hui 150 ans après
vous nous diriez que c'est quoi alors je
pense que là le l'épisode du 18 mars a
été finalement un facteur de
déclenchement puisque c'est une trace
est une trahison supplémentaires c'est à
dire que ces canons lasson récupérer en
douce puisque tiers envoie l'armée la
nuit pour éviter justement tout
mouvement de foule il sait qu'il ya un
risque d'insurrection puisqu'il dispose
ses troupes de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent paralyser tout le mouvement
populaire d'ampleur alors ce qu'il
n'avait pas prévu c'était que finalement
que les soldats fraternisent dans
certains bataillon avec les insurgés
ce qui a finalement causé comme causé sa
perte mais mais mais pour le coup je je
crois que cet événement du 18 mars a été
un facteur de déclenchement mais que
finalement le siège et les les épisodes
révolutionnaires précédent au cours de
l'année au cours des années 1870 et 1871
ont été des préparatifs à cette
explosion populaire du 18 mars
alors la caractéristique de la commune
c'est de ce printemps rouge comme vous
l'appelez c'est qu'il n'a pas de chef
et je vois bien en ayant lu votre livre
que pour vous c'est très important et
c'est d'ailleurs d'actualité au fond une
révolution qui n'a pas de chef
une révolution qui n'est pas
personnaliser comme le sera la
révolution bolchévique
la révolution communiste en chine la
révolution à cuba
toutes les révolutions au fond mon teint
leaders ont un chef
là il y en a pas alors il y en a marx
d'ailleurs à regretter il est toujours
dit si auguste blanqui avait été là la
révolution aurait eu un chef et
probablement l'histoire était différente
alors il faut se dire que blanc qui il a
fait la révolution de 1830 il avait 25
ans il a fait la révolution de 1848 il
en avait 43
il a passé à ce moment là valent plus de
22 ans en prison sur noble enfermé et et
il est de toutes les insurrections
pendant le siège de paris
mais ensuite ils sont envahis par deux
seraient posés dans le lot et irat la
commune et c'est quand même fou et vous
l'avez raconter tout à l'heure thiers
immédiatement lui met la main dessus et
le met en prison en bretagne parce qu'il
n'a qu'une crainte c'est qu'il rejoigne
la commune
c'est l'homme et les communards vont
d'ailleurs essayé d'obtenir la
libération de blanc qui parce que c'est
le chef qui leur manque
alors à la fois le fait qu'il n'ait pas
de chef c'est un avantage parce que ça
donne à la révolution une pureté
il n'y a pas de dictateur au fond parce
que tous les chefs des révolutions vont
tous devenir des dictateurs mais en même
temps c'est un problème parce qu'il
aurait fallu quelqu'un pour rassembler
tout le monde et puis surtout pour être
capable de négocier tout à fait et c'est
comme vous l'avait dit et comme on l'a
déjà évoqué tiers avaient connaissance
avait connaissance de ceux de sable de
la commune est véritablement je crois
que ce qui manque c'est ce qui manque
c'est véritablement un leader qui
puissent qu'ils puissent mener
l'insurrection alors un leader cécile
suffit pas d'un seul homme c'est à dire
que véritablement ce qu'il a manqué à la
commune
c'est un parti de masse ancrée au coeur
de paris puisque véritablement ce que
l'on voit c'est que on a toutes les
tendances politiques qui sont regroupés
au sein du conseil de la commune on a
des membres de la première
internationale on a des blancs qui sont
à des anarchistes proudhonien absolument
tout le monde mais qu'il n'y a pas de
partie rade grand parti de masse
rassembleur qui puisse finalement porté
aussi un leader naturel qui aurait pu
mener l'insurrection
alors je ne suis pas partisan de la
personnification à outrance mais force
est de constater que dans l'est
à toutes les révolutions qui ont su se
doter d'un chef charismatique ont
finalement il ya eu des résultats plus
heureux voilà mais aujourd'hui on se
dirait cent cinquante ans après on a
l'impression que la mode justement et
tôt et aux insurrections populaires sans
chef je pense évidemment au gilet jaune
mais on le voit bien à hong kong
il n'y a pas de chef non plus et alors
est ce que ce sont les réseaux sociaux
tout ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut
se passer une chef au fond et est ce que
ça ne donne pas à la commune une
certaine modernité à vos yeux de
d'adolescents je pense que c'est ce
manque de leaders charismatiques a
finalement de côté un côté extrêmement
noble et un autre côté stratégiquement
et politiquement plus problématique mais
comme je les dis ce n'est pas tant la
question d'un chef d'un leader naturel
que d'un parti de masse véritablement
ancré au sein du sein du mouvement des
gilet jaune qui était un mouvement
extrêmement extrêmement intéressant sur
ce plan là on a encore une fois il y
avait pas de parti de masse
véritablement ancré pour fédérer le
mouvement est finalement lui donnez lui
donner les moyens d'aller plus loin
puisque au final il s'est tu
il s'est beaucoup affaibli au cours
d'eau au cours d'un au cours des années
donc effectivement donc je pense que
c'est un atout sur d'un point de vue de
la fois d'un point de vue de la suite de
la pureté révolutionnaire comme vous
l'avez dit mais que d'un point de vue
politique effectivement il faut vérité
il faut pour mener une insurrection un
parti de masse et finalement le leader
naturel se dégage de ce parti de masse
oui mais un parti de masse c'est souvent
un faux parti de masse c'est le parti
léniniste le parti bolchévik en 1917 qui
n'est pas réellement un parti de masse
qui se présente comme tel mais qui au
fond opère un coup d'état alors cessé
c'est tout le problème
mais il faut il faut véritablement c'est
tout
on peut pas y échapper foot fait non je
crois qu'on peut échapper à ce que les
révolutions tournant des transforme en
dictature mais simplement il ya aussi
une part laissé et c'est tout le danger
d'ailleurs de ceux de ce2 de ce concept
de devoir la révolution menée par un
parent un leader par un leader naturel
c'est de les voir se transformer
finalement lorsqu elles obtiennent le
pouvoir en mouvement dictatoriaux ce
colloque
il n'a pas été alors certes engels
considéré que la commune était la
première la première expérience
dictature du prolétariat mais toujours
est il qu'elle a été élu de façon
démocratique et que jusqu'au bout ce
sont les citoyens et c'est la base des
militants en fait aidé des membres de la
garde nationale qui ont tenu cette
insurrection
donc après concernant concernant le
parti de masse est toujours le problème
c'est là c'est aussi il ya aussi une
part laissée à la manipulation et il
faut pouvoir en fonction des situations
décerner un vrai parti de masse d'un
appareil vaut uniquement à porter
apporter quelques uns au pouvoir mais
concernant la révolution la révolution
bolchévique
toujours est il que les bolchéviques ont
réussi à rassembler justement le
prolétariat russe et notamment dans les
campagnes pour renverser le régime
tsariste donc vériste donc je crois que
qu' il faut rester prudent sur cette
question du régime du régime bolchévique
et du coup d'état du coup d'état de
lénine en 1917 parce que c'est un sujet
vraiment très très sujet beaucoup de
polémiques et surtout très très très
précis voilà il faut on ne fera pas de
débat sur ce sujet on a deux minutes
avant la pause je propose de les les
accorder à louis rosell parce que c'est
à une des figures de la commune
on va le voir derrière moi c'est le seul
officier d'activ qui va se rallier à la
commune
il a 27 ans le garçon qu'on voit
derrière nous vous avez l'air beaucoup
plus vieux à l'époque et on va en voir
d'autres encore plus jeunes tout à
l'heure mais louis roussel
il est il est le délégué à la guerre
c'est à dire le ministre de la guerre de
la commune
il essaye d'organiser une armée face aux
120 mille soldats de l'armée
versaillaise il n'y parviendra pas il va
d'ailleurs démissionné et il aura une
fin tragique puisqu'il est évidemment
arrêté tiers va pas
être tenté de le gracier et lui va
refuser la grâce et il va être fusillé
avec un symptôme de communards à satory
donc le camp militaire près de
versailles qui existe toujours
d'ailleurs
ça aurait pu être un leader
charismatique il aurait pu être le chef
de la commune si la commune s'était
donné un chef c'est une question à la
postérité que vont poser à posteriori
c'est extrêmement compliqué d'y répondre
après ce qu'on peut voir c'est que le
personnage de russell il est extrêmement
intéressant à plusieurs à plusieurs
titres
tout d'abord il n'est pas engagé dans
les mouvements de la gauche radicale qui
qui finalement participé au soulèvement
du 18 mars et à la commune par la suite
il va rester délégué à la guerre
extrêmement peu de temps une dizaine de
jours puisqu'il va démissionner le 10
mai face au manque de moyens en
dénonçant la désorganisation des troupes
qui a toujours posé problème tout au
long de tout au long de l'insurrection
après est ce que ça aurait pu être un
leader charismatique pour la commune
c'est une question à laquelle pour le
coup je ne peux pas répondre
c'est je ne peux pas je peux pas vous le
dire et la désorganisation ça aussi on y
reviendra parce que c'est une chose
qu'on a beaucoup reproché
rétrospectivement à la commune de
n'avoir jamais su s'organiser va tout
s'est passé dans une telle précipitation
et dans un temps si court moins de deux
mois que l'on peut on peut comprendre
qu'ils aient été désorganisée ont fait
une pause
on revient juste après avec raphaël on
continue de parler de la commune
[Musique]
on revient sur les 150 ans de la commune
avec raphaël charlet qui publie
printemps rouge aux éditions maya le
bilan de de la commune pour vous c'est
quoi parce que on lui prête énormément
et la commune en moins de deux mois
elle aurait pris des décisions que
malheureusement la plupart d'entre elles
n'ont pu être entérinée puisque ça n'a
duré que deux mois mais qui sont des
décisions que l'on prendra par la suite
mais longtemps après oui effectivement
je crois que s'il ya un point s'il ya eu
ce qui fait évidemment la force de la
commune
c'est comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
le fait qu'elle est et ce qu'elle soit
extrêmement en avant en avant se
ressentent sur son temps politique
donc c'est très compliqué de dégager des
mesures phares qui ont vraiment été les
vraiment les plus importantes de cette
période mais je crois comme jeu comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure que certaines
certains certaines mesures comme par
exemple la loi de séparation de l'église
et de l'état c'est extrêmement fort et
c'est véritablement le mouvement de la
commune est véritablement un mouvement
visionnaire puisqu'on voit comme vous
l'avez dit on va voir par la suite que
de nombreux de nombreuses décisions et
et ont été reprises il ya aussi un
programme social et démocratique
extrêmement important par exemple le
fait que les ateliers vide et été
réquisitionnés et que leur direction
soit donnée aux ouvriers c'est je pense
qu'aujourd'hui où on a de très gros
problèmes de démocratie au sein des
entreprises et notamment au sein des
grandes firmes ce qu'on appelle les
galets gaza par exemple google amazon
facebook et apple que justement c'est ce
genre de décisions je choque qui
quittent arrange vraiment avec eux avec
la réalité de du second empire soit
vraiment des modèles et puisse encore
nous inspirer pour la décision politique
à prendre à l'avenir alors la liberté de
conscience est assurée par par la
commune
mais effectivement il ya un premier pas
vers la séparation de l'église et de
l'état puisque on arrête de financer les
cultes même si on laissera les gens
priaient dans les églises
la liberté de la presse vous insister
dessus les garanties en tout cas au
début de la commune dès l'instant où les
versaillais attaque
en revanche ça devient différent mais on
est en guerre mais au départ il laisse
paraître des journaux qui sont hostiles
à la commune il ya des élections libres
on l'a dit
y a pas de chef on l'a dit aussi c'est
sur la place des femmes que c'est
intéressant la commune d'abord parce
qu'elles sont omniprésentes on va tous
se retenir la figure de louise michel
qui est institutrice à ce moment la
martre et qui va participer à toutes les
tentatives d'insurrection pendant
pendant le siège de paris et qui va être
très actif pour la commune qui sera
déporté d'ailleurs en nouvelle calédonie
ensuite avec les communards mais c'est
vrai qu'elle n'a pas le donner le droit
de vote aux femmes alors on n'a pas eu
le temps non plus haut en deux mois mais
les femmes sont extrêmement présente
tout à fait et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
j'ai voulu mettre en avant sur la
couverture de mon livre puisqu'on y voit
tout simplement une gravure de la
barricade de la place blanche tenus par
des femmes donc qui était omniprésente
dans le dans le dans le combat
communards elles ont notamment laissé
des souvenirs leurs noms dans des
souvenirs chez les versaillais avec
notamment l'image que vous avez évoqué
des pétroleuses c'est à dire ces femmes
qui mettent le feu au bâtiment pendant
la semaine sanglante
alors on a en général ce terme de
pétroleuses ça reste quand même une
image dont on ne peut pas prouver la
véracité
mais en tout cas c'est elles ont
vraiment eu un rôle de premier plan
un rôle politique et évidemment c'est un
set et un 17-1 des manques de la commune
c'est qu' il n'y a pas eu véritablement
de grandes décisions prises pour les
femmes notamment la question du droit de
vote qu'il n'aura jamais été accordée en
attendant on a tendance à penser comme
vous l'avez dit que véritablement
c'était pas un manque de temps et que le
l'appui des femmes dans le combat
communards est véritablement la preuve
qu'il n'y avait pas de qui ne l'est pas
de volonté de maintenir les femmes un
statut inférieur à celui des hommes mais
que c'était véritablement tout à fait un
parement de
par manque de par manque de temps et par
par la pression de la guerre aussi qui a
fait que tout le programme de la commune
n'a pas pu être appliqué tel qu'il avait
été élaboré dans ses premiers jours
il ya aussi un bilan négatif de la
commune et c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
qu on ne commémore pas la commune
aujourd'hui on commémore napoléon mais
on commémore pas la commune
la ville de paris organise des
expositions mais il n'y a pas de
commémoration officielle nationale
alors ce bilan négatif c'est d'abord les
exécutions et ça commence tout de suite
comme ça par deux généraux qu'on exécute
enfin il s'apprêtait à tirer sur la
foule vous ne direz de 18 mars mai mais
enfin bon on les exécutent si elle est
réglée les ecclésiastiques qu'on va
arrêter
on peut d'ailleurs passer un moment avec
raul rigaux on va le voir derrière moi
vous en parlez dans votre livre est
le garçon qu'on va on va voir apparaître
était le chef de la préfecture de police
à paris pendant la commune il avait 25
ans 1
c'est à dire qu'il est il et il paraît
plus vieux mais mai n'a que 25 ans
ensuite il va devenir le procureur et on
va lui reprocher toutes sortes
d'exactions d'ailleurs y compris pendant
la commune mais c'est vrai que ces
fusillades puis ces incendies au moment
de la semaine sanglante quand la commune
préfère détruire les bâtiments plutôt
que de se rendre célèbres mais elle fait
aussi bien à l'hôtel de ville qu'au
théâtre de la porte saint-martin est ce
c'est à paris plein de ruines qu'on va
voir qu'on va venir visiter d'ailleurs
il va y avoir un tourisme des ruines à
paris après après la commune
les anglais et les allemands vont venir
visiter comme salaire 8 de paris paris
c'était quand même la plus belle ville
d'europe sous sous sous napoléon enfin
sous napoléon iii et et c'est vrai que
c'est terrible après la commune j'ai
l'impression que le bilan négatif de la
commune ces deux choses là les
fusillades
d'un côté et les des structures de
l'autre oui je pense que ça je pense que
ça y participent
maintenant concernant alors je vais
répondre sur les sur les deux aspects
concernant les fusillades effectivement
on a des mouvements de colère populaire
qui s'exprime au moment du 18 mars et
qui fait que finalement des généraux
comme clé clément thomas o claude
lecomte qui sont les deux généraux tués
juste après juste après la reprise des
canons par les parisiens sont finalement
victime de cette colère populaire qui
déferle sur eux alors même qu'ils
s'apprêtaient quand même
comme vous l'avez rappelé a fait retirer
sur la foule des parisiens présents et
insurgés c'est effectivement un bilan un
bilan une partie du bilan négatif
maintenant ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
voir aussi c'est que le la commune en
elle-même n'a jamais n'a jamais n'a
jamais prôné ce type d'exécution c'est
véritablement des initiatives soient de
cadres de la commune comme vous l'avez
dit raul rigaud qui fait exécuter
plusieurs excès que plusieurs
ecclésiastiques comme par exemple à la
toute fin de la toute fin de la
surrection monseigneur d'arbois
l'archevêque de paris qui est exécuté
mais donc ces initiatives sont plutôt
celles de cadres comme vous l'avez dit
raul rigaud que véritablement de
l'ensemble de la commune de même sur les
deux mêmes sur les incendies alors déjà
il ya deux types d' incendies pendant
pendant la semaine sanglante
les premiers se sont les incendies
d'immeubles qui sont dus à une technique
et une tactique militaire c'est à dire
que la défense de paris se fait par des
barricades
les parisiens dressent des barricades à
chaque crue qu'ils défendent et les
versaillais plutôt que d'attaquer
frontalement les barricades et de rester
et de risques et de nombreuses pertes
préfère attaquer sur les flancs percer
les immeubles et de les déborder la
commune tout simplement sur les côtés
alors pour ceux pour se prémunir de ces
de ces attaques là les communards met le
feu aux immeubles qui sont adjacents aux
barricades aux barricades et heureux
qu'ils défendent donc ça se sent ça ce
sont des incendies véritablement dues à
la guerre et non pas due à une volonté
de détruire paris ensuite concernant
concernant de les incendies de deux
monuments tels que par exemple l'hôtel
de ville là on est plutôt sur des
initiatives de groupes isolés
il ya notamment une un documentaire qui
est passé sur marseille a pas très
longtemps qui s'appelait les damnés de
la commune où donc on suit une héroïne
dont je ne me rappelle plus de jeunes
voire quelques du nom et son parcours au
sein de au sein des événements de la
commune et on voit finalement qu'elle se
elle décrit une forme d'effroi vis-à-vis
de vis-à-vis de ces images d'un incendie
notamment de l'hôtel de ville et on voit
que finalement ce sont des initiatives
de groupe
deux groupes relativement relativement
isolé et que c'est difficile de les
attribuer véritablement à la commune se
sont ils sont perpétrés par certains par
certains des communards mais ce ne sont
pas des directives de la commune puisque
tout simplement au moment de la semaine
sanglante à la fin on avait plus
véritablement d'organisation le conseil
de la commune étaient tt était de fait
dissoudre puisqu'une bonne partie de ses
membres été soit tués soit refusé de
siéger soit été faits prisonniers ou
étaient portées disparues donc il n'ya
plus véritablement direction et ça fait
que ce type d'exactions
certes condamnables ne sont pas
imputables à la commune en tant que
régime politique
alors là la répression la semaine
sanglante particulièrement féroce on l'a
dit j'ai l'impression que depuis 150 ans
la gauche baigne dans la mythologie de
la répression et plus la répression et
violente plus la gauche est exaltée et
j'ai l'impression que ça remonte à la
commune et on la vit très bien vu dans
la mythologie des manifestations telle
qu'elle a plu c'est là qu'elle a pu
fleurir au moment du mouvement des chez
les jaunes très vite on a oublié les
revendications le départ pour ne plus se
concentrer que sur la répression
policière
et à force tout ça n'avait plus aucun
sens c'est à dire que l'on manifestait
contre la répression la répression la
répression évidemment s'exerçait sur la
manifestation est la suivante était
encore contre la répression
j'ai l'impression que la la le la halle
dans bilan négatif on pourra dire de la
commune il ya cette espèce de 2,2 j'ai
l'impression que ça tourne en rond ça
tourne en ondes depuis 150 ans on
cherche la répression pour pouvoir se
révolter contre la répression
alors je ne crois pas que je ne crois
pas que l'on cherche la répression au
contraire je pense qu'il ya une réalité
dans la répression des mouvements d
mouvements sociaux de tous genres depuis
depuis finalement le 19e siècle et que
et que finalement c'est une réalité
qu'il nous faut combattre la répression
j'ai moi même été dans des
manifestations où on avait des
comportements de la part de certains de
certains de certains acteurs contre
contre contre contre les manifestants
véritablement incompréhensible et
insupportable donc je crois que la
répression c'est une réalité et je ne
pense pas que il y ait une recherche de
la répression pour mieux la condamner
mais au contraire il faut il faut la
dénoncer
et surtout il faut il faut il faut
montrer à ceux qui ne participent pas
aux manifestations à ceux qui ne sont
pas politisés que c'est que cette
répression est une réalité
alors certes il ya répression et la
pression c'est à dire que on ne
considère pas de même face de la même
façon une manifestation dans laquelle on
a deux ou trois blessés bien que ce soit
tout de même dans le cas où ces déplacés
comme souvent inacceptables et la
répression qu'on a pu voir pendant la
semaine sanglante avec avec des dizaines
de milliers de tués mais je pense que le
problème de la répression se pose encore
et doit et doit surtout nous interpeller
et nous faire lutter pour la démocratie
et contre véritablement c'est cesser ces
pratiques là qui sont indignes d'une
véritable démocratie
on voit bien que la répression s'est
beaucoup adouci entre guillemets 1
depuis 150 ans il ya je n'ai pas
contraire voilà non on est on est bien
d'accord mais si j'étais le président de
la république si j'étais le préfet de
police
et si j'avais un mouvement de
contestation populaire en face de moi je
sais que le meilleur moyen de le
neutraliser et qu'on oublie ses
revendications qui pourraient aller
limite séduire le reste de la population
si je ne veux pas qu'on parle des
revendications et ben en gros j'ai
intérêt à mettre un peu de répression
suffisamment pour que ensuite on s'élève
non plus contre les injustices conte et
dénonçait au départ mais pour qu'on
s'élève contre la répression et ensuite
on ne parlera plus que de la répression
ne parlera plus jamais des
revendications qui
pourtant on fait naître ce mouvement
c'est ça que je veux dire c'est qu'en
fait depuis la répression de la commune
il ya un piège qui s'est refermé contre
tous les mouvements populaires tous les
mouvements revendicatifs qui est celui
de dénoncer la répression pendant que
vous dénoncez la répression vous ne
dénoncerai pas les injustices à je
comprenais ce que vous voulez dire mais
je pense qu'effectivement c'est une
stratégie et qu'en plus aujourd'hui
alors des réseaux sociaux et de la
médiatisation de masse effectivement
c'est cette stratégie s'avère encore
plus payante
néanmoins dans la plupart des cas la
répression n'occulte pas les
revendications
par exemple on a eu on a eu lors de lors
des manifestations des gilet jaune de
très nombreuses scènes ça sonne de
scènes de répression et et pourtant les
idées n'ont pas disparu c'est à dire
qu'on avait de très nombreux médias qui
s'acharnait à répéter que finalement on
ne connaissait pas les revendications du
mouvement des gilet jaune alors que
pourtant sans forcer sans nécessairement
aller à leur contact mais tout
simplement dans l'univers médiatique
lorsqu'on entendait parler des
manifestants on comprenait véritablement
ce qui était ce qu'il demandait et est
tout simple tout simplement leurs
revendications
auxerre c'est une stratégie médiatique
également de masques et de masquer les
demandes et les revendications d'une
d'un peuple en révolte mais pourtant je
crois que aujourd'hui à l'ordre où on a
des des médias qui tolèrent parfaitement
que dès qu'on parle politique même sur
des oeufs sur des chaînes d'information
en continu on peut reprocher ce qu'on
veut aux chaînes d'information continue
mais de temps en temps on a quand même
des intervenants qui n'hésite pas acquis
qu'ils n'hésitent pas à parler
franchement des problèmes véritablement
politique et non pas simplement de ces
aspects-là de répression donc je pense
qu'on peut encore parler de politique
grâce aux manifestations qu'on peut
encore faire parler de politique grâce
aux manifestations et que certes la
répression est un outil médiatique mais
que pourtant le poly la politique en
elle même reste encore reste encore bien
présente et qu'on veut surtout faire
qu'elles soient bien présente
autre actualité de la commune que vous
pointez dans votre livre
raphaël charlet
c'est justement la démocratie directe au
fond c'est avec la commune que se
matérialise une forme de démocratie
directe à vos yeux et et notamment
quelque chose qui a été beaucoup plus
évoquée par le mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'est la révocabilité des élus
oui alors cet aspect de la révocabilité
des élus il me semble extrêmement
important de même que cette je crois je
crois à la démocratie représentative
néanmoins je pense qu'il demeure
important de consulter la population de
consulter les citoyens sur des grandes
décisions
par exemple dans le cas où on voudrait
comme comme je le souhaite et comme je
suis pas seul à le promouvoir
finalement convoqué des élections pour
conserver pour constituer une assemblée
constituante pour élire pour finalement
changer de république est passé une
république plus parlementaire et plus
démocratique
je crois que par exemple je crois qu'on
a besoin dans des situations comme ça de
rupture de consulter directement les
citoyens c'est à dire qu'ils ont le
droit de vote et je pense qu'ils doivent
s'ils doivent être consultées yale
souverain sur les grandes décisions qui
les concernent
maintenant effectivement la révocabilité
des élus c'est un sujet qui est porté
par de nombreux qui est promue par de
nombreux partis et mouvements politiques
et je pense que c'est une idée qui va
faire son chemin
le mouvement des gilet jaune l'a évoqué
il n'a pas été le seul
il y en a eu bien avant qu'ils ont qui
ont émis cette idée
je pense notamment à jean luc mélenchon
lors de la campagne présidentielle de
2007 qui défendent est déjà cette
proposition donc je pense que
effectivement il y a des il ya des des
idées d'avenir qui émerge de tous les
mouvements sociaux quels qu'ils soient
et finalement qu'il faut savoir écouter
ses revendications la et les prendre en
compte notamment sur la question de la
révocabilité des élus encore demandait
la démocratie puisque certes on peut
être critique comme je le suis vis-à-vis
du mouvement vis-à-vis du mouvement des
gilet jaune mais il faut quand même
reconnaître qu'il ya certaines idées
extrêmement intéressante extrêmement
novatrice aussi qui ont émergé de ce
mouvement et qu'il faut savoir les
prendre et et et pour véritablement
faire avancer le monde politique
d'aujourd'hui mais
véritablement pratiquer la révocabilité
des élus pour dans les communes alors
7,7 révocabilité était a été mise en
place
maintenant c'était la situation était
plus compliquée qu aujourd'hui parce que
le mode de scrutin n'était absolument
pas la même c'est à dire qu on élisait
un certain nombre de sièges par
arrondissement on votait le départ de
ces tests était d'aider liste nominale
certains élus pouvaient être pouvez
obtenir un siège dans plusieurs
arrondissements
de plus d'autres d'autres de d'autres
élus ont refusé de siéger après que la
participation dans leur arrondissement
était trop faible et qu'il ne se
considérait pas comme légitime
donc il ya eu des élections partielles
maintenant est-ce que la révocabilité
des élus a été exécuté elle était
possible mais est-ce qu'elle a été
utilisée en tant que tel je ne crois pas
néanmoins elle était juridiquement
juridiquement envisageable alors parmi
les enseignements de la la commune vous
dites qui a la capacité du peuple à
décider par lui-même
vous venez de nous l'expliquer il ya la
possibilité de re distribution des
richesses vous voyez dans la commune une
révolution anticapitaliste alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya de l'autogestion parce que
les patrons les propriétaires des usines
sont partis donc les ouvriers s'organise
pour faire tourner les usines faut pas
oublier qu'à la suite du siège de paris
a énormément de chômage à paris et qu'il
faut que non seulement les usines
marchent mais il faut travailler il faut
il faut qu' il faut que la vie continue
en fait si on veut que la commune
continue mais est ce que pour autant
on limite le travail à 10 heures par
jour mais est ce que pour autant
c'est une révolution anticapitaliste on
ne parle pas de collectiviser les moyens
de production par le pas d'abolir la
propriété privée on a souvent dit que
cette révolution communiste l'aco but
mais est ce que ça l'est vraiment alors
c'est une excellente question
la commune est elle une révolution
communiste je pense que le terme de
communistes et tout d'abord anachronique
mais également qu'il n'est pas
parfaitement exact je pense que la
commune est une révolution qui a été
marxiste puisque alors au delà du
soutien de mars qu'il a témoigné à
l'insurrection notamment à travers son
livre la guerre civile en france et de
la participation des mouvements de la
première internationale
je pense qu'il y a eu une une prise de
conscience politique et notamment un
programme social et démocratique
extrêmement important sur la question de
la redistribution des richesses par
exemple je voulais évoquer tout à
l'heure le fait que les ouvriers
puissent désormais faire tourner soit
désormais leur propre patron dans les
ateliers déserté par ceux ci je pense
que c'était une révolution
anticapitaliste
c'était une révolution marxiste je pense
que le terme de communisme est un petit
peu prématuré bien qu'on considère
souvent que la commune soit le premier
le premier est le premier est un des
seul exemple de gestion véritablement
communiste je pense que cet anachronisme
et que c'est un certain point un petit
peu un petit peu un petit peu compliqué
à dénouer je ne pense pas que le terme
de communisme soit parfaitement exact
bien qu'il puisse s'y appliquer je pense
que le terme de marxistes et plus juste
aujourd'hui la commune pourrait servir à
quoi
dans une perspective politique et qui
est celle dans laquelle vous vous situez
vous même en écrivant ce livre en quoi
peut-on utiliser la commune quand on a
16 ans en 2021 alors à plusieurs titres
tout d'abord à titre
à titre d'exemple de mobilisation
populaire on voit aujourd'hui qu'on a
extrêmement de mal à faire descendre
acer descendre des gens dans la rue
extrêmement de mal à mobiliser que ce
soit comme je viens d'évoquer dans la
rue ou d'un point de vue électoral aussi
donc je pense que c'est un exemple de de
mobilisation populaire il ya un élément
qui est extrêmement fera pendant les
élections du 26 mars au conseil de la
commune c'est que les quartiers
populaires sont écartés qui votent le
plus a parfois 65 % ce qui est
absolument énorme skis véritablement
fait une crime différence par rapport à
aujourd'hui
donc je pense que cet exemple je pense
que cet enseignement là le fait que l'on
puisse véritablement faire en sorte que
la population se re politise est déjà un
exemple
ensuite il ya évidemment le point de vue
programmatique puisque les avancées sous
la commune sont quand même on a déjà
évoqué extrêmement importante et est
surtout très très très très voilà ce
sont des innovations
donc je pense que ce point là est
important et enfin tout simplement le
fait qu' il y ait un engouement pour des
cours des valeurs anti capitaliste des
valeurs de solidarité qui je pense sont
des valeurs ce sont des valeurs d'avenir
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas dans quel
état on sortira de la crise sanitaire
sanitaires et politiques
mais je pense que les événements de la
commune et les révolutions qui l'ont
précédé peuvent nous servir de peut-être
de guide pour essayer d'imaginer ce
fameux monde après il ya la nécessité de
l'union des forces progressistes pour
vous parce que ça c'est vraiment voilà
quand on réfléchit avec commune
c'est déterminant oui absolument pas ce
que le conseil de la commune a été régi
par des forces politiques extrêmement
diverses je l' ai déjà dit on a eu les
scénaristes pour dounia aux côtés des
membres de la première internationale
aux côtés des bloquistes et aujourd'hui
on voit que finalement à à gauche on a
un très grand nombre de courants
politiques qui refusent de s'entendre et
pourtant je pense que si on veut éviter
le pire aujourd'hui la nécessité c'est
l'union de ce qu'ils veulent de ceux qui
veulent véritablement créé qui de ceux
qui veulent véritablement un changement
politique et donc je pense que la
commune où on a fait collaborer des gens
qui venaient d'horizons politiques aussi
divers est un bon exemple pour nous
aujourd'hui pour construire l'avenir
politique immédiat et c'est pour ça que
l'union des forces progressistes comme
je l'appelle a réussi autant de la
commune et je pense qu'elle peut encore
réussir aujourd'hui bien évidemment que
les biens bien évidemment les contextes
politiques ne sont absolument pas les
mêmes mais je pense que ça reste un un
exemple façon on dit aujourd'hui que les
que les idées de gauche que la gauche en
général la gauche politique est atone
qu'on ne l'entend plus que la france
s'est résolument droitisée on dit
d'ailleurs que les jeunes de alors un
peu plus âgés que vous ce qui veut tron
l'année prochaine ben de votre
génération vont plutôt voté pour
emmanuel macron et que ceux de la
génération juste avant qu'ils ont entre
25 et 30 on veut plutôt voté en majorité
pour marine le pen
on a l'impression que les idées de
gauche aujourd'hui c'est terminé
vous avez sentiments vous aussi qui
avait 16 ans j'ai pas le sentiment que
ce soit terminé du tout en rangée le
sentiment qu'on les entend plus et je
pense que c'est inquiétant puisque
effectivement on a un discours
médiatique qui est très orienté c'est à
dire qu'on déroule le tapis au duel
installé entre le président de la
république et et marine le pen et donc
on a un
la gauche est plus ou moins rendu
silencieuse dans une bonne partie des
médias je pense notamment aux chaînes
d'information en continu qui se plaisent
à invité ici un représentant de la
république en marche ici un
rassemblement il ya un représentant du
rassemblement national mais beaucoup
plus rarement des représentants de la
gauche radicale
donc je pense que ce silence médiatique
qui est plus fort qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
est plus important qu'il ya quelques
années
participent au fait que effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya moins de porter la
gauche à moins de porter à moins de
portée politique
maintenant elle est extrêmement faible
et c'est exact dans dans l'art ma gauche
j'écrivais que elle était divisée mais
elle était forte
ce qui à l'époque quand on observait le
total des voix aux dernières européennes
par exemple cumulés par le bloc de
gauche était vrai aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les sondages en vue des
élections présidentielles ce qu'il faut
se dire c'est qu'on n'a jamais eu et
c'est qu'on a jamais eu autant de
candidats à gauche et que le total des
voix 2 des intentions de votes attribués
à ces candidats n'a jamais été aussi
faible
donc il y
il faut il est urgent je pense de
redynamiser la gauche politique et
aujourd'hui on nous force est de
constater qu'on ne va pas dans le bon
sens merci raphaël charles est d'avoir
passé toute cette émission avec nous
printemps et merci à vous c'est votre
nouveau livre ça vient de paraître aux
éditions maya merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]